award-winning novelist Colson whitehead
is considered one of America's greatest
storytellers the New York Times
bestselling author made history by
becoming the first writer ever to win
Pulitzer Prizes for two consecutive
novels he's also one of only four people
who have won - he won in 2017 for the
Underground Railroad and this year again
for the nickel boys which is out in
paperback today it tells the story of
Elwood Curtis a young black boy who is
unfairly sentenced to a harsh harsh
juvenile reform school in the 1960s
Colson whitehead joins us from his home
in East Hampton New York good morning
Colson thanks for being with us
congratulations on the on the two
Pulitzer Prizes you were here before
when the book first came out I can't
remember whether but whether you'd won
yet but that's a pretty cool feat I want
to talk about this book again because it
seems so relevant today I mean it's
about it takes place in the 1960s and
it's about an actual real reform school
or sorry it's based on one which which
you actually visited why why did you why
did what made you pick that stoop that
story what was it that made you want to
tell that story well you know it all
comes around you know again and again so
after the summer of 2014
with the Ferguson protest and Michael
Brown being killed I came across the
story the Dozier school of reform school
in Florida a lot of abuses I never heard
about it and it seemed the same way that
we have these police brutality events
caught on video how many are we not
seeing and so if there's one place like
does your how many other reform schools
that are terrible and abusive
are there and so stuck with me so the
idea the book was born out of that
terrible summer of 2014 and here we are
again and here we are again I mean
you've seen this before you grew up in
New York in the 1980s I grew up in New
York in the 1960s I feel like I've seen
this story before but the conversation
often ends up fading out do you feel
that it actually may be different this
time you're correct we talked about
police brutality and have a car
station that dies out and in 80s in New
York was Eleanor bumpers Michael
Griffith I think this time does feel
differently you know I've written two
books recently one about slavery what
about Jim Crow and we see how much has
not changed but it does seem in terms of
how widespread the protests are and and
how big and prolonged that and we have
seen you know a few local city and state
police reform efforts put in so you're
encouraged it does seem very different
civil state I'm encouraged reluctantly
you know there's somewhat reluctantly
contrary that's interesting okay I know
that feeling well you found when after
you wrote the Underground Railroad you
found that something very interesting
about your own aunt ancestry what was it
exactly well as doing a lot of
interviews and I would say that you know
have so many ancestors so I don't know
about because they're lost in a void of
slavery and so I had a uncle who got
very mad and said don't you know about
this person I voted about that person so
there's a man named Colson who's a slave
in Virginia in the 1840s 1850s who
bought himself out of slavery and then
kept working and then bought his
daughter out of slavery well you were
named after you know they're like I've
named after Colson yeah so you know I
ancestors who died in plantation the
ancestors who were freed who freed
themselves and that's like the black
American story there's so many different
kinds of ways of being enslaved in this
country and some of us needed it out
your your previous book the Underground
Railroad is being made into a series by
Barry Jenkins for Netflix I believe can
you can you tell us anything about that
for Amazon yeah oh no yeah ten episode
miniseries one of the last things I did
before lockdown was go to the set I was
just really sort of magical to see a
hundreds of people
the story to life and bury such a genius
so I look forward to coming out you know
I didn't really have I had one
suggestion that they didn't take it was
that a sort of Allah Eddie Murphy and
the clumps or dr. Doolittle all the
white people should be played by Walton
Goggins this one actor where I like he
usually pays like two rednecks so like
old white lady little white kid Walton
Goggins they did go in that direction
weirdly nice to look forward to seeing
how it how it turns out well that's
great I look forward to that and I
gather you finished a new novel about a
crime novel that takes place in the
Harlem which I really look forward to
during the pandemic you finished it
that's great news Colson whitehead thank
you so much the nickel boys is out in
paperback today